we are back with more of our
conversation with Amal and a drawer Amal
and George Clooney look at the way these
two look at each other I can't get over
this the power couple joined us in
studio on a very big day for them it was
their eighth wedding anniversary they
told us all about falling in love
raising their kids and the one thing
they say they've never done
as we sit here today it's your eighth
wedding anniversary yes and George
people said George Clooney's at the time
a mall George Clooney's getting married
yeah yeah come on man married eight
years yeah because you were known as a
confirmed Bachelor but you met Amal
Clooney and what happened to you George
I was no longer confirmed it was easy it
was the minute she walked in the door I
was just you taken by her and uh and the
fun part was you know we didn't I didn't
know whether you know she would like me
or any of those things and then uh wait
George stop it and then we would know if
them all would like you yes and you know
and and then you know she's this
extraordinarily you know fun smart
beautiful great woman and you know it
was I was just very taken with her and I
started writing her letters what did you
like what what did you find me actually
what did he say them all in the last
um some of them came from his dog and it
was it was sort of you know who's gonna
be mad at a dog the dog the dog needed a
human rights lawyer to rescue him from
The Wine Cellar I remember that so you
of course knew who he was them all but
were you taken with him too
or did you think he's a Hollywood movie
star I don't know I met him and I
thought I'm so glad that there's someone
like him in the world I didn't
necessarily
imagine that I would get to spend my
life with him or that we would have this
incredible family yeah so now we took me
by surprise he screwed my life I was a
life was easy for me
yes yes what do they do guys that just
Delight you because I know at five they
are very chatty you know and I but we've
made a terrible mistake what oh well we
we bought them Italian oh but we don't
speak Italian oh okay so we've armed
them with a language that they can harm
us with that's true and we don't really
know they both speak Italian and French
so our son is now a big prankster and
he's he's basically you've taught him
all of these lessons and he's now
pranking his dad back Alexander's
favorite superhero is Batman and he goes
you know I said what's your favorite
superhero he goes you know Batman and I
go you know I was Batman and he goes
yeah but not anymore
I was like if only he knew how how true
that was well people are so delighted
that you're together and somebody told
me once you know whenever you're talking
to a couple the question isn't how do
you make it work it's how do you stay
together what is it that you give to
each other that makes you stay together
I think it starts with Love George I do
think that well it does I would love and
yeah it's sort of the whole secret to it
it's never ever been even it's funny
that's not even a question that we would
even think of I mean it's just been easy
listen has it been easy easy like the
easiest thing in our lives by far we've
never had it's imagining to some of our
friends I have a cousin actually every
time we see him he's like his first
question is so have you had an argument
yet
would you like us to right now it could
be a first no I think that it's a
hundred percent well I would say it's 99
luck just to meet the
I think
the one thing I think we would take
credit for in a way is just to not be
cynical to just be open
um and I was surprised that you were not
cynical or guided at all and things just
moved really quickly that's sort of one
more question for you all because I
cannot cook my children will have no
memories of mom used to make fill in the
blank but until then he tells a common
story about you not even boiling an egg
properly I thought he was exaggerated
I'm afraid it's all true so when you
actually put an egg on the stove with no
I'm sorry we don't need to get into the
detail when we first got I thought I
tried to do the cooking thing and yes
you know I tried to make it fun I bought
eight prints and I had music and a glass
of wine and I would do this and then I
realized that every time I cooked he
would make reservations suddenly it
would be date night so now I know what
to do if I ever want to go out for
dinner
I'm sort of those during the covet I was
the yeah thank goodness you look at her
with such awe honestly Joy you do like
well I I mean what's not to look at I
know I got it I get it by the way it's
our anniversary and we're spending it
with you yeah that's true I couldn't
think of a better way to spend your
anniversary could you no George Goes
actually yes I could Gail okay thank you
guys oh we really want to be here with
you
I heard from very reliable sources they
had a little date night last night just
uh just to make dinner but it really is
something about the two of them together
I do think it's very real I think there
were some eye rolls from married couples
as they never had an argument I I think
they have no reason to lie about that
right they are so very much in sync yeah
and very devoted to their children of
course which by the way they've managed
to keep private you see no pictures of
them right they want them to have as
normal life as possible and raise happy
healthy responsible kind kids that's
their definition of success so I mean I
think the final argument as Patty
pointed out our stage manager uh but you
know the other thing is the mall
mentioned he's a prankster he's a
legendary and one of the best dad pranks
he's ever pulled off which a lot of dads
copy now is works with toddlers you take
the diaper off the toddler with a clean
diaper you put peanut butter or
chocolate inside and then hand the
diaper back to the baby the baby starts
eating it and then you act distracted
like you're on your phone
and then your partner comes in it's like
oh my God oh my God
the rude prank you know and they're big
Alby Awards the first you know George is
already talking about next year uh it's
a big thing tomorrow night in New York
City at the library and guess who they
got for entertainment Bruce Springsteen
and his wife Patty scialfa who's also a
singer and his wife it's going to be a
great show Meryl Streep all those people
at this point in this in their lives
they could just be selfish but they're
so selfless yes that's a very good way
to put it and guess what you can watch
George Clooney we love him here at CBS
on The Late Show with Stephen Colbert
he's going over to Stevens tomorrow
night right here on CBS